vous avez pu imaginer un seul instant
que 30 ans après tout ça le la situation
pouvait se tendre à nouveau de manière
aussi exceptionnel avec la russie oui
bien sûr vous avez vu les choses venir
elle serait dé ce qu'on a raté on
compare la relation avec eux on parle
d'une longue période 1 oui mais oui
après la fin de la brigade c'est pas la
chute du mur c'est la fin de lurs après
la fin de l'urgence on a dù la russie
c'est là qu'il ya un nom pas tout de
suite mais pendant des années yalcin et
donc non le souvenir des russes on leur
dit la démocratie de zaoui la démocratie
et alice in l'effondrement du niveau de
vie à la corruption pour les russes et
ça c'est les années eltsine à l époque
où il est conseiller américain dans les
ministères russes la demande des russes
imposer la thérapie de choc 40%
d'effondrement du pouvoir d'achat 40%
dans nos pays si les gens pensent qu'ils
ont perdu 0,5 ils sont en révolution bon
donc après il ya eu le mandat poutine
poutine 2 puis medvedev et une longue
période je pense comme la plupart des
américains vétérans de la guerre froide
que l'occident a accumulé les erreurs et
des provocations et des maladresses ce
n'est pas par complaisance par rapport à
la future russie est redevenue
nationalistes partisans
désinvolture ignorance on a gagné on a
gagné globalement et on s'en fiche un
peu de ce que pensent les russes les
chinois les arabes et les africains donc
ça c'est une période après après il ya
le début de l'évolution notamment à
partir de poutine 3 est une solution
vraiment nationaliste d'ailleurs annoncé
par poutine dans des discours et autant
l'occident à mon avis c'est délicat dans
le débat aujourd'hui parce que quand on
voit les horaires en ukraine et les
bombardements c'est presque gênant mais
est quand même il faut comprendre le
débat lieu aux états unis beaucoup plus
que dans les débats chez nous 1 donc
après on n'a pas été assez inclusif au
début dur même qui singer la regrettée
ça on n'est pas construit un système de
sécurité qui est imbriqué la russie et
dans un second temps toutes les
dernières années on n'a pas été assez
dissuasif et pas été assez ferme il faut
bien distinguer ce qu'on parle de 30 ans
donc depuis poutine 3 il ya un danger
évident évident même avant la firme
crimée et après etc etc
mais il ya une responsabilité de la part
des occidentaux dans ce qu'est devenu
poutine et ce qui l'a amenée
aujourd'hui dans un colloque historique
on pourrait le dire oui mais c'est
délicat à manier en tout cas et c'est
pas que la russie à l'assemblée générale
des nations unies il ya eu un vote après
l'agression de poutine et les relations
est évidente mais pas contestable et
puis la guerre est atroce etc on voit
tout ça 140 pays ont condamné très bien
une quarantaine de pays a refusé de
condamner
quarantaine de pays qu'ils représentent
démographiquement 60 % de l'humanité il
ya là dedans il a évidemment la chine
mais aussi l'inde donc quand même pas un
point l'idée qu' on est les maîtres du
monde ne l'avant-garde morale du monde
ces dates de répondre nos valeurs nos
critères nodar médecin de sa faut que
les occidentaux réfléchissez dessus est
ce que ça fonctionne pas que la russie
c'était dingue ans un peu désinvolte
c'est la même chose qui a conduit à
faire entrer la chine dans l'organisme
mondial du commerce alors qu'elles n'ont
respecté aucune règle est ce que les
occidentaux se sont dits à l'époque on
va les faire rentrer ils vont se
développer et ça va les rendre
automatique en démocratique donc il ya
quand même une série de d'absurdité quoi
donc faut qu'on atterrisse en ce monde
là en gardant évidemment viscéralement
nos valeurs mais il faut comprendre qu'
on va être obligé de réinventer la
coexistence pacifique avec les uns les
autres mais pas avec les rues si
maintenant on peut pas se l'urgence
c'est d'arrêter la guerre et la
souffrance non voir un jour on pourra un
jour et inventer quelque chose avec la
russie pour vous un jour mais il faudra
y aura toujours la russie à côté
[Musique]